hey guys welcome to game of love and i'm
your host lisey today i'm accompanied by
two handsome bachelors ryan and lucas do
you guys want to introduce yourselves
sure i'm brian i'm 23 i'm from torrance
california i'm an actor director creator
and for fun i like to play basketball i
box and i love to take photos i'm lucas
i'm from redondo beach california i'm
also an actor i'm also um an aspiring
firefighter and i like camping i like
biking and i like building stuff hey
he'll come in handy
today's game is tug of war suitors when
it's your turn line up behind the
bachelor you'd like to date
[Music]
these are your teams you have five
minutes to speed date each side starting
now
let's get the kindergarten questions out
of the way favorite food french fries
mac and cheese japanese ramen i love
fries too but i could love a good poke
bowl as well sushi oh same sushi um mine
is mole it's a mexican dish dave's hot
chicken i like fla which is like a
vietnamese noodle soup okay all good
answers i'm not a raw fish person so i
can't do sushi who or what is your style
inspiration anything really off on guard
i could be caught in sweatpants or just
like in a whole fit i really like like
parisian fashion like elegant classy
modern glam like something that really
accentuates my long legs tyler the
creator it's like i literally look up to
him with style truly who doesn't i would
say like edgy but like
build it up to make it like more fancy i
like to play around i thrift a lot cool
thrifting is awesome save the planet
in terms of the amount of confidence she
has when she wears anything i really
just want to have the same energy as
dolly parton i love that answer style
inspo is definitely my mom because her
style rocks so yeah
that is the end of the speed dating
round lucas do you have a side you
prefer
i think i'm gonna go with the red team
would you like to add a player from the
bench
no let's do evens
suitors there is a flag in the middle of
the rope and two lines on either side
whichever line it crosses first is the
winning team on my whistle
begin
[Music]
blue team
you guys are eliminated and that's the
team you wanted
so you are now stuck with the blue team
not stuck all right welcome to the speed
dating round brian you get to speed date
these lovely ladies for 10 minutes on my
whistle go
[Music]
what are you guys red flags and a guy
starting from you one of the things that
i usually look out for is empathy gotcha
a persistent liar
how they treat people around them so if
we're going to a restaurant and they're
rude to a waiter then he's going to have
the same treatment towards me negativity
from the inside comes outside um prefer
when they have a bed frame
that's probably the biggest one what's
your idea for like a first date i really
enjoy going on picnics at parks and
sometimes painting and doing photography
and yeah sometimes there's like a
pressure of like
who's paying for who on like if you go
to like a fancy dinner so i'd rather
like maybe like cook at home together
eat like a light meal
i love going out to dinner um if we end
up
vibing i guess you should say um going
out to the bars after if not that's your
scapegoat dinner's over and you can run
out of there cool going out to one of
our favorite restaurants so that way i
can either try out what you like or you
what i like so you might try something
new definitely going to the restaurant
first but if it goes well
then just walking around and looking at
stuff cool
brian do you know what side you prefer
i'm gonna say
blue team blue team do you want to add
someone to the side that you prefer
yeah i'll take the uh the girl in the
far right
on my whistle
tug of war
[Music]
blue team wins congratulations blue team
red team unfortunately you have no shot
with brian you did good though
boom
the same rules apply but this time you
have five minutes to speed date each
side and then at the end if you prefer a
side you can always add someone from the
bench but you don't have to
all right let's get into nitty gritty
stuff like a red flag and then the
opposite of a red flame a green flag
whatever you call it red flag uh they're
selfish or they don't have a job
um a green flag would be somebody who is
very
like outward driven so they're selfless
people something i really like
is open-mindedness because i feel like i
get along with a lot of different type
of people on the opposite side
close-mindedness someone that values
money too much
and a green flag would be someone
that knows how to communicate their
feelings i say a red flag if you don't
know how to take a piece of the humble
pie like sometimes it's like in a heat
argument like we need to all just sit
down and if you are just aggressive
about it i just it gets to a bad place
a green flag totally would just be like
if you're spontaneous and you're social
i would vipe off somebody it's like that
a red flag is somebody who's always on
their own time a green flag is somebody
who wants somebody to just
be friends with and also like be
romantic with do you guys have
ex-boyfriends ex-girlfriends
sir so what ended the relationship my
ex-boyfriend he'll probably be watching
this i don't care i broke up with him he
was a very
conceited and arrogant person the last
person i was seeing is kind of two
different personalities looking for
different things yeah didn't work out no
one's been lucky enough to be my ex here
i love that that's awesome
me and my ex um we completely moved to
different sides of the country that will
just never work oh it was the distance
you didn't move because you hated each
other no it was it was no it was
literally the distance and probably just
will never align so i'm just like just
do your thing i'll do my thing i
was with somebody for on and off for
like two years i think we both like did
not trust each other enough to
kind of even go there
do you have a side you prefer no yes the
i guess i'll go with the blue side and
would you like to pull someone from the
bench to help the blue side i will
write my wrongs and add someone to the
blue side all right who would you like
to pick i don't think i got names so
yeezys go
yeah you get up here
[Applause]
i'm so sorry but you don't get to date
all right same rules apply you have five
minutes now to speed date these lovely
ladies cool i'll be back
are you guys family oriented yes um
pretty much just me and my immediate
family since i'm living across the
country from them right now it's kind of
hard but i see them probably once a
month family first always
i live for my family's happiness
i'm very close to my family um my
immediate family's the only one in
california so oh wow yeah we just stick
together for sure are you guys friends
with your ex no uh
no okay
are you friends with your ex
no
would you try to be friends with your ex
i would try to be on good terms
ryan do you have a side you prefer i do
have a side that i want to help out
let's get you helping out red
i got you thank you
same rules apply on my whistle tug of
war
[Music]
congratulations you are now a finalist
and now you guys are going to tug a war
to see who the next finalist is
you guys are competing for brian's final
slot i know you guys just became besties
and i'm sorry to do this but on my
whistle
tug of war
you are now the finalist good job good
job you have five minutes to speed date
each side and if you prefer a side at
the end you can always choose someone
from the bench to help them out
let's
go back to x's all right i know you
haven't had an x so we'll make an
exception are you friends with your ex
and if you are
why if you aren't why not so i have two
exes but my most recent ex
blocked
would never talk to him again one guy i
was seeing sometimes we'll talk so we're
friendly
and then the other guy i just don't
really talk to anymore i feel like i'd
definitely try to be friends with them
unless it was toxic than popping that so
what's like toxic
like if they make me question my values
i feel like that's toxic to me
i'm going to add someone from the bench
to the red team all right let's see what
happens who's yolked molly
oh
all right congratulations you are a
finalist
you guys will compete against each other
to see who the next finalist will be
all right on my whistle you guys will be
competing for lucas's final spot are you
guys ready
where did it even end wait
i'm confused we might need to watch a
playback because i think it crossed here
okay okay we got it
and the winner
of the tug of war contest is
drumroll please
all right lucas this is the final round
do you know who you're picking
yeah
sure are you confident in that answer
yeah yeah okay you need to be confident
because i'm giving you a shared cash
prize that you can use on your first
date
whenever you're ready right on you guys
are both like seriously such amazing
people like i've only known you guys for
however long but i think
i'm going to go with
[Music]
eddie on this one
[Applause]
you okay
brian this is the final round do you
know who you're picking
i think so are you sure
yeah because i'm about to give you a
shared cash prize that you're going to
use on your first date
so be positive
sure hit it ladies
let's see
i'm gonna have to pick
[Music]
good job
where did it even end